liberals have a new reason to wet the
bed the Millennials are moving to the
right according to the New York Times
the critical part The crucial part of
the Democrat party's electoral Coalition
that helped put Barack Obama in the
white house has started voting
Republican as they get older
shock all right Jesse are you shocked I
mean when we're young you tend to be
rebellious when you get older you tend
to be a little more responsible uh what
is your take away from this I don't have
a takeaway I talked to sources in the
polling industry who gave me this
takeaway what they say is this is
economic they say in 2008 you have the
crisis in the housing market and since
then their economic Futures have
flatlined their housing purchasing power
is not they have not gotten the wage
gains they expected and so they're kind
of Trapped where other Generations were
able to really Advance economically they
have not been able to do that and
they're frustrated the people a little
bit older than they are are very
concerned with inclusivity they're more
concerned about being judged by other
moms for not being inclusive enough so
on the one hand you get Generation X who
really just cares about being accepted
socially and not being called a bigot
and then the people generation whatever
Millennials are they just want to make
more money and they don't care about
Equity all right so Dana should the
Democrats be troubled by this and do
they have a game plan to try to work
this I don't know if they have a game
plan on this I think this is probably
inevitable maybe a little bit factored
it in and gen Z has woken up in a big
way if you look at the vote turnout in
that Wisconsin Supreme Court election
they had like an 80 turnout and on the
college campuses and they were voting
mostly against abortion so the
Republicans have lost some of the
college-educated men and women and
college-educated men and women who are
now Millennials who are having children
and they can't find a house to buy and
they're frustrated with a lot of things
the Democrats will try to run up the
score on abortion the bigger problem
that Democrats have is with Hispanics
because that number is that is
definitely decreasing for Democrats so
we'll see how that goes you know see and
Bernie Sanders Greg said you know what
just charge everybody more taxes now
this generation is at the point where
they're paying taxes is that part of it
that's it in fact uh think work pray no
think work okay pray love you're getting
I'm gonna do an impression of you in a
second think work and pay is the eat
pray and love of a generation embracing
reality it's you see a young woman that
Embraces the rights of abortion all of a
sudden starts thinking about actual
children right you're seeing this shift
for three as you get older right this is
where I become Jesse you become less
attractive right so you care less about
what people think you care less about
what people want yeah
you discovered that virtue is this one
Don Lemonwood yes exactly but you
realize that virtue signaling is for
suckers you have to start dealing in the
substance of reality you care less about
what people think and more about what
you can do to make your family better
you start paying the bills you write two
checks on April 15th it feels like
you're being assaulted because you get
zero from it and you start a family you
enjoyed pride month Jesse brunching all
the time Jimmy Greg is all year round
you had you had rainbows in your
apartment even when they weren't outside
but now that's starting to look like a
luxury you were for Trans rights but you
don't want trans activists telling your
kids which pronouns to use that's what
you do as a parent so as you age
these like uh what Tyrus would call like
first world problems first world issues
and you start dealing with real world
issues and all this stuff looks like
garbage okay Jessica wrapping up
okay so as the only Democrat at the
table no I will say someone speak now or
forever hold your peace I'm an old
school Democrat
it's another Kennedy thing with you
um
this is just what happens and people
come back around when they've either
they've made a lot of money right so all
the mega donors are boomers right and
they're all 60-something sitting in
board rooms giving out hundreds of
millions of dollars to whatever causes
that they please this is the Natural
Evolution as yes you start to pay more
in taxes you have a family
um
was that directed at me as a 39 year old
Democrat I do think and Nate Cohn who
put out this piece and did the polling
on it noted we don't know the true
impact of the Dobbs decision that this
is a kind of seismic shift in terms of
the political
Jackson V dogs a woman's right to
control her own body cone
don't there's no e don't be
we know you can't spell
anyway
um so we we got to see how strong this
shift ends up being but of course you're
going to be concerned at any time that
you could lose the point is you've
become more conservative as you've got
if you had a family you have related yes
what you have you said build a wall in
the green room I heard you yeah
coming up Greg's worst nightmare has
come true what it is next on the five
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else